riesen explosion in einem wohngebiet in
eckernförde am dienstag erschüttert um
11 uhr plötzlich ein knall die
nachbarschaft im gartenhaus des
reihenhauses seiner eltern hat ein
19-jähriger mit chemikalien hantiert bei
dem versuch selbst böller herzustellen
kommt es zur explosion
ich saß am kaffee tee schon hab kaffee
getrunken ein bisschen gewandelt
da gab es auf einmal einen ganz ganz
schrecklichen knall und mir gesagt was
dann die haare zu berge und ich habe
mich so erschrocken habe ich aus dem
fenster guckt oktober to god und das war
wie eine atombombe wieso ein pilz der
aufgeht die feuerwehr ist im großeinsatz
der junge mann erleidet bei der
explosion schwere verbrennungen
er wird in eine spezialklinik nach
lübeck gebracht laut polizei bestand
zunächst lebensgefahr
ich habe bald im herzen vor gericht also
ich habe wahnsinnig was ich gedacht auch
im moment ich habe erst mal gedacht das
ist die marine die hat irgendwo ein
fehlschuss gegeben
das war richtig schrecklich so muss man
sich fühlen sag ich mal jemanden fähig
vielleicht miterlebt ich weiß es nicht
also ich habe jetzt noch gänsehaut dazu
schreiben
das gartenhaus ist völlig zerstört
überall liegen splitter und scherben im
wohnhaus befanden sich zum zeitpunkt der
explosion familienangehörige
sie wurden nicht verletzt wir ermitteln
hier weil der verdacht besteht
herbeiführen einer sprengstoffexplosion
das ist der grund warum auch das lka
hier war und die spur noch gesichert hat
noch ist unklar mit welchen chemikalien
der 19 jährige hantierte nachbargebäude
wurden durch die explosion nicht
beschädigt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren